نصف سكان المانيا خائفون على مصير
الديمقراطيه بلدهم التي يقترب عمرها من
سبعه عقود بعد ان شلت السلطات الالمانيه
في الشهر الحالي حمله امنيه واسعه استهدفت
مجموعه ارهابيه مرتبطه بحركه مواطن راخ
اثرى محاولاتها الانقلاب على الدوله خوف
الالماني على نظامهم ديمقراطيه اظهره
استطلاع لقياس مؤشرات الراي اجراه معهد
يوقف توصل الى ان ثلاثه وخمسين في المئه
من الالمان يرون بالحركه تهديدا
للديمقراطيه الدوله محصنه والاغلبيه
المطلقه من المواطنين لا يشعرون
بالديمقراطيه فحسب بل يعتقدون ايضا ان
الديمقراطيه تستحق الحمايه
الحركه التي بدات ثمانينات القرن الماضي
ويجمع انصارها بين الايمان باستمراريه
الامبراطوريه الالمانيه ورفض الاعتراف
بدوله الحاليه يتسارع سعيها لاقتناء
الاسلحه بل تلقى بعض افرادها تدريبا على
كيفيه استخدامها وفقه تقارير استخباراتيه
ومؤخرا كشفت الاجهزه الامنيه عن محاولات
لتجنيد افراد سابقين وحاليين في الجيش
الالماني رغم انها عاده ما تجذب اليها
اشخاصا يعانون من مشاكل ماليه واجتماعيه
وفقه تقارير محليه عده الحركه اليمنيه
التي فشلت في انقلابها لا يجتمع انصارها
على انتماء واحد فبعضهم من النازيين الجدد
فيما يطمح اخرون لتعيين ما يصفونه بملك
الرايخ الالماني حنان المصري العربي